you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess comm
and I just got done working through
several tactics of them I've selected
three and they're all endgame related so
feel free to treat this video as if it's
a little bit of a pop quiz for each of
these three I'll give you a little bit
to pause the video see if you can work
it out and I'm just gonna dive right in
and share what the solution is and some
of my thoughts that I had along the way
when trying to solve so for this first
one again go ahead pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white okay
the solution of this one is what you
might expect for move one at least but
there are other there are multiple
variations to consider at least two the
first key move here is to just
immediately approach the pun I must
admit that one of the things I thought
of was to go here so that I'm King takes
pawn we go here and we have a little bit
of an opposition type thing going on
however this isn't quite cutting it
because black can play h5 and then well
now our two pawns down we got to get one
of them back King takes pawn King g3 and
this pawn will soon promote so it's
important that we immediately approach
the pawn and put pressure on them
knowing that on King takes pawn we just
take here and the King doesn't have this
resource he can't make use of g3 and
safely advance the pawn next because the
timing just is not there we're tracking
down the H pawn the variation to
consider is that on King here
suppose King g6 this is an important
moment what are we doing here there's a
couple a couple moves one is to maybe
play King e5 the other is to play H 5 H
5 isn't going to work on h5 King takes
pawn we would capture this pawn however
black doesn't have to capture the pawn
if we're playing here King f6 now we're
forced back
and we're soon to be down a second pond
something like this might come about and
well both black ponds survived so in
this position after king f4 king g6 the
move would not be h5 but rather king e5
and now after h5 which is really the
only move for black at this point if
we're going back here we're just
repeating so the last key moment last
thing to really work out is what exactly
to do should black play
h5 what is the key King move in this
position the key move here is king to d4
it's very important at this point to
anticipate that when we move our king
black we'll be able to make use of f6
next with their king well the only way
we can stop black from getting to f6 on
their next move is if we play King to e6
but in that case this pawn just takes
off so we're going to have to give up
control of f6 and we basically want to
be in a position to stop the King from
playing to one of these two squares next
be six and e5 and the only way to really
do that is to play first King d4 so that
we can meet King f6 with King d5 this is
very important
and this is really the key idea in this
very simplified endgame that after
there's h5 move we have to go to first
d4 King f6 and then King d5 how is it
different if we make use of d5 right now
King d5 King f6 now what King here the
pawn takes off King here now the King is
starting to sneak over and soon black
will continue to be able to advance the
pawns successfully even track down the H
pawn if I'm to just put out some more
moves here just to show something like
this might come about and soon we're
seeing that another pawn is scooped up
and black will go on to win so this is
really the key move it's a few moves
down the road here after king f4 king g6
king e5 and h5 it's important to see
this next key move and it is king to d4
king f6 king d5 what does black do if he
goes back here we go back here and we're
winning this pawn next if this pawn
starts to run well we can hunt him down
and this will be a draw
okay so let's move on to puzzle 2 where
there's a little bit more involved some
more pieces besides kings and pawns this
one right here where it's white to move
so again if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white okay the big
thing I noticed with this one when
trying to work it out is that it is
incredibly important you get the move
order correct this is a classic case of
a B or B a you have two different moves
in mind which one should be played first
move order most certainly matters one of
the ideas white has is to checkmate the
black King and this is one of the first
things
that captured my attention and it was
the black King not having so many
options available he's currently in
stalemate he and the black king has no
legal moves and we have ideas of King F
for controlling this Square and then
rook takes pawn King takes pawn rook h1
checkmate there's a problem with this
however if we play King F 4 on our first
move so the idea here we're looking at
the moves King F 4 and then the next
move of rook captures pawn within the
the final shot rook h1 but the question
is which of these first which of these
moves should be played first when you
kind of have to work out the differences
between the two if you're playing King F
for first notice black has Bishop takes
pawn
also notice that we're down a minor
piece as white this plays a role if
we're playing King F for first notice
Bishop takes pawn is available now there
is no rook takes pawn King takes pawn
rook h1 because there's a second option
for black King F for Bishop takes pawn
let me just put it on the board King F
for Bishop takes pawn rook takes here
there's Bishop takes King takes rook we
would have checkmate and I mean there's
even this option here but we're not
getting at you know this isn't enough
this isn't the best that we can do we're
getting a bishop but we can do better
the trickier is to switch the order to
force the King to the h5 Square right
now the key move here the winning move
is rook h5 in fact this is a checkmate
in three black has to take and only at
this point King f4 move order matters
rook takes pawn or King f4 and first
move rook takes pawn first and I don't
care what black does on the next move
rook h1 is mate next tricky and
this was my first thought maybe many of
you can relate I was looking at King F
for first but you have to realize the
defensive resource that black has to
invest that material back on g6 and we
won't be mating if we go with this move
first okay let's have a look at just one
last one where we have a rook each okay
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white okay I must admit
this is one that I didn't get I was
maybe a little bit too lazy or I don't
know maybe just the idea I don't know I
just didn't I didn't get it for whatever
the reason didn't spend a whole lot of
time trying to work it out but yeah
in the end I got this I did not get this
one I got I got a correct incorrect so
the winning continuation is to first
play rook to b7 the the thing that I was
trying to work out is well how can i
this is what I would like to have happen
you know rook b7 king c8 then we go here
with Czech and then finally we can push
with Chuck you know and then give check
and then give Chuck and then promote
the problem with that is that on rook b7
the King doesn't have to go to see it if
he's going here we get to do this and
then this next and will soon be pushing
through with our pawns we won't need our
king's help
the thing to sort out is what to do
after King a a it's the only other thing
to work out well only at this point only
after we have forced the King on the a
file can we actually go ahead and just
snip that each pawn so what's the trick
here this pawn is going to drop rook
takes a what are we doing here
well we're giving the pawn back rook a7
with the fork the rooks are traded and
guess who's stopping the H pawn
no one white goes on to win this pawn
cannot be stopped for whatever the
reason this this little idea of a follow
up fork along the a file eluded me I
didn't get this one but a nice little
move sequence to be familiar with two
pawns on the sixth rank possibilities
for a rook move I mean you could do this
right away and you're threatening a mate
and one but after rook takes a here
there isn't a way to force the rook
exchange so it's actually a very clean
solution here and I like this one rook
b7 first get them on the same file as
the rook some tactical ideas when
multiple pieces are on the same file
rank or diagonal rook takes pawn and
only after the King is on that a 8
squared do we have this little trick and
off the H pawn goes and he will not be
stopped
okay well I think it was a nice little
group of three
endgame puzzles feel free to leave any
feedback let me know how you did in the
comments section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now
take care